tenez plus sincères pensées aux deux
victimes de l'attaqué commise vendredi
dernier devant le 6 août que la paix en
panne et s'adresse aussi à leurs proches
et à toutes les personnes qui ont
continué à travailler à cette adresse
depuis l'attentât commis contre la
rédaction du journal charlie hebdo nous
mêmes mes pensées vont également à toute
la rédaction de ce journal à nouveau
attrapé par le terrorisme alors que se
tient actuellement le procès des
attentats de juillet 2015 de très
nombreuses informations utiles diffusée
sur cette affaire depuis vendredi
certaines sont exactes d'autres non
certaines seront factuel donc
susceptible de rendre qu'il difficile
par les enquêteurs la loi quant au
procureur de la république
la possibilité de procéder à une
communication objective la plus complète
possible tout en préservant les
impératifs des investigations et les
droits des personnes
c'est le sens où intervention
d'aujourd'hui au moment où il enquête de
flagrance camion c'est ici les faits
tout d'abord lé enquête menée sous
l'autorité du parquet antiterroriste a
permis de préciser lors des rounds
ainsi le 25 septembre 2020 à 11h33 un
individu masculin portant des chaussures
rouges et survêtement gris et un sac à
dos et passe une première fois dans
l'entrée du 6 rue nicolas-appert s'y
trouvait à ce moment là un homme âgé 32
soit une femme de 28 ans qui fumait une
cigarette à proximité immédiate d'une
fresque en hommage aux personnes tuées
par les frères cauchy une vingtaine de
secondes après ce premier passage
l'individu est revenu sur ses temps
cette attaque est subitement d'abord un
homme puis à la femme en l'enracinant de
nombreux coups notamment à la tête avec
un hachoir qu'il venait de sortir de son
sac à dos
rick les victimes parvenait l'une après
l'autre à s'enfuir dans des directions
opposées
l'auteur des faits les a brièvement
poursuivi avant de quitter les lieux
la durée totale de l'agression d'une
extrême violence
un peu disney entre 15 et 20 secondes au
cours desquelles et viti tous deux
travaillant à cette adresse ont été
sérieusement blessés je précise que
cette agression a été filmée par une
caméra de surveillance
ainsi c'est sans la personne de sexe
féminin plusieurs plaies fractures au
visage
ok constaté occasionnant au moins 10
jours d'itt été ou sera victime de sexe
masculin
la présente plusieurs fractures du crâne
est toujours hospitalisé dans un état
très grave son unité est estimé à au
moins trois mois à l'issue de cette
attaque
l'auteur a pris la fuite en empruntant
la liberté le boulevard richard lenoir
avant d'entrer dans la station éponyme
à 11h40 et c'est d'abord du son à
premier quai puis sur le cas opposé
et alors brièvement échangé avec une
seconde de cette dernière
rapidement placé en garde à vue a été
loin totalement mis hors de cause
l'anc est en effet démontré que cet
homme avait trop contraindre fait preuve
d'un grand courage
on essaie de rattraper de mise en cause
pour m l'auteur des faits a ensuite
emprunté la ligne 5 du métro en
direction la place d'italie mais s'est
ensuite déplacé dans le quartier il a
finalement été interpellé à 12h35 au
sein du métro bastille à proximité
en quoi c'est sur les couteaux à cran
d'arrêt n'a mérité au regard de ces
éléments et compte tenu tout d'abord dû
mieux conditions des feux ensuite de
leurs temporalités saut au moment précis
du procès des attentats de janvier 2004
most hid confesse de revendications des
menaces émanant d'organisations
terroristes à la concurrence charlie
hebdo et enfin de la volonté de tuer
manifesté par l'auteur l'encontre de
glace et ce n'est certainement pas le
parti anti terroriste s'est saisie à
13h45 jour des faits il a confié enquête
conjointement à la drpj
je salue le directeur décolleté et
alléger les constatations elle ajouté
l'elysée bien entendu nicolas pères
principalement elles vont rapidement les
mises en évidence que l'auteur des faits
avait laissé sur place un sac dans
lequel on a retrouvé deux bouteilles
d'eau explique des marques de morceaux
de tissus sains marqué et bienne 3
septembre par ian scoones de hassan
anime les cartes sim elle a retrouvé
d'avoir proximité une troisième ou tel
ou atypiques lambic lui même la choix
n'a été retrouvée abandonnée ou richard
lenoir l'enquète elle s'est d'abord
rapidement attaché identifier les
différents à domicile de l'auteur ainsi
vendre un logement situé dans nos
classes sociales val d'oise dans lequel
nous en cause résister en juin 2000 2020
parts on est assis pétitionner sans
apporter d'élément utile à l'enquêté
de la même façon le domicile actuel nous
en cause si tu attends ça été
perquisitionnés a permis de saisir son
téléphone ainsi qu'un autre hachoir
plusieurs personnes vont cohabiter avec
l'auteur présumé
jean logements ont été placés en garde à
vue sauf que leurs déclarations ne
renfermant en quête d'autres personnes
de son entourage amical
farinas ont également fait l'objet de
garde à vue au cours de ces derniers
jours
à ce stade toutes ces mesures ont été
levées parmi ses amis
certains ont évoqué le fait que mise en
cause regardez abondamment ces derniers
temps les vidéos irradié hussein les
fondateurs et dirigeants du parti terek
et les pays-bas keystone dlp qui a
organisé au pakistan ou du mois de
septembre dernier des manifestations à
lacets de la nouvelle publication des
caricatures d'hommes
par ailleurs le téléphone est mise en
cause est il qu une vidéo datée du 25
septembre à 8h02 durée de deux minutes
59 secondes dans laquelle l'intéressé se
met en scène dans cette vidéo qui sera
également diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux
il s'exprime en ourdou et se présente
sous le nom cité de verre
hassan même identité sur laquelle je
reviendrai sans aucune précision
il annonce son geste à venir lundi qu
ici en france de fond les caricatures
sur notre curé plus grande diane et mai
prochains mois aujourd'hui le 25
septembre
je vais aller me révolter ce sens pour
le reste le mis en cause dans cette
vidéo où fleurs évoquent dieu salomi
puis et diraient certains il y as kadri
qui pourraient être identifiés comme
fondateur l'obligation religieuse d'un
watt islam cependant j'ai fait
allégeance à aucun groupe terroriste en
particulier doit primer les faits a
déclaré lors de son placement en garde à
vue cela mais hassan ali et est né le 10
août 2002 au pakistan lors de
l'exploitation de son téléphone il a
toutefois été découvert la photo d'un
passeport pakistanais au nom de zaher
hasan mahmud ne le 21 janvier 1995
également au pakistan et supportant sa
forme après avoir contesté
l'authenticité de ce document
j'ai finalement reconnu qu'il s'agissait
de sa véritable identité et qu'il était
donc âgé de 25 ans en tout état de cause
ce ses diverses identités de mise en
cause était totalement inconnu de
l'ensemble des services de renseignement
judiciairement jamais été condamné mais
il a fait l'objet en juin dernier d'un
rappel à la loi pour attendre à un
projet vise qu'à limiter les soupapes
il a ajouté avoir quitté le pakistan en
mars 2018 être arrivé en france au mois
d'août de la même année passée par
l'iran la turquie l'italie
il s'est présenté à saly sociaux val
d'oise le 17 août 18 cette fausse
identité de la salle me il a été alors
pris en charge en tant que mineurs non
accompagnés entre le 17 juillet
9 le 10 ou 20 toujours sous cette fausse
identité
il a également fait l'objet d'un suivi à
l'assistance éducative par un juge des
enfants du tribunal de pontoise
s'ils ne bénéficient d'aucun titre de
séjour d'un rendez-vous prévenu au jour
des faits à la préfecture du val d'oise
à propos de sa situation à présent ces
déclarations la de manière constante
reconnu la matérialité des faits il
indique avoir regardé ces derniers jours
des vidéos en tendance pakistan et vont
encore la publication initiale puis la
nouvelle publication des caricatures de
mahomet ainsi que les manifestations que
cet événement avait suscité dans son
pays en colère selon ses propres termes
il a décidé de s'en prendre journal
chaque dose il ya donc fait des
recherches qui ont permis d'identifier
l'immeuble de la rue nicolas-appert sent
qu'ils sont informés que le journal ait
déménagé à la suite de l'attentât du
mois de janvier 2015 pour préparer son
acte il a reconnu avoir procédé à des
repérages l'a10 mme 22 et 24 septembre
dernier
ce que l'exploitation de son téléphone
et de la vidéosurveillance a permis de
corroborer le jour des faits elle s'est
rendue la salle ni pour un soir ainsi
que mme arthaud est trop ardu de white
spirit qui ont été retrouvés à proximité
des lieux
l'examen de la vidéosurveillance
commerce la fessée acquisition a permis
de confirmer qu'il était seul lors de
ses achats
son projet initial était d'entrer dans
les locaux du journal
éventuellement si nécessaire alec
marteau de les incendier grâce au bout
des doigts de pieds en arrivant devant
la rive 6 nicolas appert et en
apercevant les victimes il a pensé que
ces dernières travaillé pour le journal
satirique et a finalement choisi de les
attaquer la garde à vue le mis en cause
a été levé aujourd'hui à 12h35
à l'issue du délai légal de 96 heures en
matière terroriste
l'intéressé sera présenté cet après midi
un juge d'instruction dans le cadre
d'une information judiciaire ouverte des
chefs de tentative d'assassinât en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
et d' association de malfaiteurs
terroristes à caractère criminel devra
notamment s'attacher à établir dans
quelle circonstance il a pu concevoir
des projets et s'il a bénéficié d'un
quelconque soutien des réquisitions ou
son placement en détention provisoire
ont été prises
je vous remercie
il a reconnu que ce passe temps c'était
dans son téléphone portable de parthenay
mais vous avez vérifié auprès des
autorités pakistanaises
je ne peux pas encore dire plus pour
l'instant l'instruction certainement que
mettra d'avancé sur pas de ces
investigations on peut affirmer qu'il a
25 ans je peux vous le dire ce que j'ai
dit et rien